[Music]
Mandy Moore and James Corden steal the
show at the 2017 costume Designers Guild
Awards
Tuesday night though this is a star
hosted the event and totally channeled
duchess Kate Middleton on the red carpet
turning heads in a sheer red Jenny
Packham gown
the actress then opened the show with a
hilarious speech admitting she's happy
to take credit for choreographer Mandy
Moore's work in la-la-land hosting
tonight's show is actually one of the
highlights of my year and third is
everyone thinking that I choreographed
lala lands and I can't really bring
myself to correct them so I just smile
and I say thank you so much
the choreographer shared the same
sentiments about the mix-up of names
when et chatted with her earlier this
month this has been going on for like 15
years okay so this is right this is
hysterical to me that it's now become
like a thing you know because it's been
a thing of my life for a long time
another highlight from the evening
Corden presenting Meryl Streep with an
award I remember the first time I met
Meryl I walked over to the table and I
said hello I'm James and she looked me
right in the eye and I will never ever
forget it she said to me I'd like the
lemon crusted salmon and a diet coke
with no ice so what I'm trying to say is
and it's time that someone said it she's
a complete [ __ ]
she is the worst I'm joking of course
[Music]
you